A RAY OF HOPE:
I’m sure you’ve all heard that Steve Jobs
died of pancreatic cancer, and technically,
this is true.
He died of respiratory arrest due to a pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumor.
But, maybe, he didn’t have, or atleast he
could’ve delayed his death by years if not
even a decade.
You see, while Steve Jobs did have pancreatic
cancer, there was a silver lining in that
he had a special form of pancreatic cancer
caused by islet cells.
Regular pancreatic cancer only has a 5-year
survival rate of 1.8%, but islet cell tumors
have a 5-year survival rate of up to 93%.
Something that swung the odds even more in
Jobs favor was that he found the cancer extremely
early.
Jobs wasn’t even at the stage at which he
was experiencing symptoms due to the cancer.
In 2003, he was actually suffering from kidney
stones, and when doctors performed a CT scan,
they just happened to notice a shadow on his
pancreas.
So, if Jobs took quick action, he could have
very well extended his lifespan by a substantial
amount, but he chose not to.
In fact, he consistently delayed medical treatment
over and over again for the rest of his life.
For example, given Steve Jobs wealth and status,
he probably could’ve scheduled a surgery
within a week of finding the tumor.
But instead, he decided to wait 9 months by
which point the cancer had already spread
to his liver.
Another example of Jobs’ stubbornness was
when he refused a liver transplant from Tim
Cook despite desperately needing one.
Jobs said that he didn’t want his body to
be opened and that he didn’t want to be
violated in that way.
And while that’s understandable, this was
literally a choice between life an death.
Also, I don’t think anyone wants to be violated
in that way.
People go through these procedures because
they have to.
But instead, Jobs felt that the best course
of action was to stay on a strict vegan diet
and use herbal remedies and acupuncture.
While these choices may offer benefits in
day to day life, there’s virtually no scientific
evidence that they help with cancer.
And given that Jobs was the founder and CEO
of what would eventually become the largest
company in the world, you would think that
he was extremely rational and objective with
these choices.
But, that was far from being the case.
People that knew him speculate that he felt
that the problem would just disappear if he
ignored it.
This line of reasoning had worked for him
in business in the past.
After all, his job was to literally create
unimaginable products and convince the world
to use them.
But, this approach didn’t quite work within
the medical industry.
Aside from Jobs reality distoration glasses,
something that was pushing Jobs to make these
choices was his spiritual life and especially
his beliefs regarding Buddhism and the afterlife.
Jobs even said “Maybe it’s ’cause I
want to believe in an afterlife.
That when you die, it doesn’t just all disappear.
The wisdom you’ve accumulated.
Somehow it lives on.”
So, here’s the story of how Jobs developed
these spiritual beliefs and how they eventually
played a role in his demise.
THE HIPPIE:
Taking a look back, Jobs spiritual beliefs
predate his cancer by decades.
In fact, he was a hippie for basically his
entire life which is not that surprising given
the time period in which he grew up.
If you’re not familiar with hippies, these
were a group of people that rejected traditional
middle class life which they felt was dominated
by materialism and repression.
Instead they embraced openness, peace, and
experimentation.
They were known for vegetarian diets, holistic
medicine, and of course psychedelics.
Jobs was especially interested in the latter
and regularly experimented with them throughout
his late teenage years.
For him, this wasn’t just a matter of getting
“high” or trying to live life more fully,
but it was actually a coping mechanism that
he used to deal with the pain that his birth
parents abandoned him.
According to Jobs, psychedelics along with
primal screaming opened up stored trauma in
the medulla.
Jobs took many of these habits and beliefs
with him to Apple.
One frowned upon habit that he took with him
was his tendency to not take showers.
Jobs believed that his commitment to a vegan
diet meant that he had flushed out all of
the mucus from his body.
So, theoretically, he believed that he shouldn’t
have a body odor and that he didn’t need
showers.
Ironically, this is not even true.
Vegan diets tend to skew away from proteins
which play a significant role in the body’s
detoxification process.
So, Jobs’ vegan diet likely meant that he
should’ve taken more showers, not less.
And let’s just say his coworkers strongly
agreed.
Another unique trait of Jobs was his tendency
to walk around barefoot.
He felt that walking around helped him think
and be more creative, and there is some truth
to this.
Moving around does energize our brains and
it reduces stress making it easier to focus
on singular thoughts and ideas.
But, Jobs didn’t just walk barefoot, he
did some weird things barefoot.
Jobs liked to sink his feet into cold water
to destress, and this seems completely harmless
at first, and it should be if done like a
normal person.
Maybe you could fill a bowl up with water
or maybe even buy a pedicure bowl.
But instead, Jobs sunk his feet into toilets
at the office.
I suspect that this only made his body odor
worse.
It wasn’t just his body that he did these
weird experiments on either.
Jobs also practiced his hippie anti establishment
mindset in other facets of his life as well
like his car.
Jobs wasn’t a fan of having a license plate
on his car for some reason.
When questioned about it, he simply said that
he didn’t have a licence plate because he
didn’t have a license plate.
The way that he made this work was by getting
new leases every six months.
California law allowed people to not have
a license plate for the first six months after
getting a new car, and Jobs exploited this
loophole until he died.
It wasn’t till 2019 that California finally
patched this loophole.
While all of these likely just seem like odd
quirks, Jobs strongly believed in each and
every one one of them.
And these unorthodox choices carried over
to his medical choices as well.
THE BUDDHIST:
If you thought Jobs’ hippie behavior itself
was extreme, then you haven’t heard about
his spiritual life.
From his college days, Jobs was especially
interested in Buddhism.
This interest was initially sparked out of
necessity as opposed to curiosity.
You see, as a broke college student, free
food was a gift.
And, one of the places that offered free food
was the Hare Krishna temple near Reed college.
Every Sunday, Jobs walked seven miles to the
temple just to get free food.
But, very soon, he walked away with much more
than just food.
Jobs became especially interested in Mahatma
Gandhi and a Hindu sage named Neem Karoli
Baba.
Pretty soon, Jobs was talking to his friends
about this sage and his teachings.
And given that most of his friends were hippies
themselves, they were pretty open to ideas
of peace and enlightenment.
Eventually, they would get to a point where
they wanted to go meet Neem Karoli Baba in
real life, but they just had one issue: they
were still broke.
But, as fate would have it, an opportunity
would arise.
At the time, Jobs was working as a consultant
at a game development company called Atari.
One of their most popular games was pong,
you’ve probably played it.
Pong gave Atari international notoriety and
a company from Germany would buy a whole warehouse
full of circuit boards from Atari.
Unfortunately though, Atari didn’t quite
make a good first impression given that half
the boards didn’t end up working out of
the box.
Naturally, the German company wasn’t very
happy and they wanted someone to come out
there a fix them.
Initially, Atari’s founder Nolan Bushnell
sent over a tech guy to Germany, but this
guy just made things worse, so Nolan turned
to Jobs.
He told Jobs that he would book him a first
class round trip ticket to Germany and a 5
star hotel if he could go fix this issue.
Jobs agreed to take the job, but he had one
condition.
He wanted a one way ticket to Germany and
wanted the rest of the travel expenses in
cash.
Additionally, he negotiated that once the
job was done, he was gone and that’s exactly
what happened.
He finished the job in Germany and he went
to India with Dan Kottke.
Unfortunately though, India didn’t quite
live up to his expectations.
First of all, the guy they were trying to
meet, Neem Karoli Baba, had already died a
year before this, and they simply hadn’t
heard the news yet.
Jobs also quote “found India far poorer
than he had imagined and was struck by the
incongruity between the country's condition
and its airs of holiness."
But, by far the worst part of the trip was
the constant sickness.
The duo picked up lice, infections, and worst
of all, uncontrollable diarrhea.
By the end of the trip, Jobs had lost a bunch
of weight, but what he didn’t lose was his
belief.
While his belief in Hinduism decreased, his
belief in Buddhism became stronger than ever.
REFUSING SURGERY
When Jobs returned to the United States, he
implemented many buddhist principles into
his day to day life.
One of his strongest Buddhist beliefs was
that everything happens for a reason and that
nothing is random.
This was one of the ways that he coped with
being fired from Apple in 80s.
He eventually came to accept that none of
the successes that followed this event like
Pixar and the iPhone would’ve taken place
if hadn’t been fired from Apple.
He also adopted a much more pragmatic perspective
when it came to death.
“Remembering that I’ll be dead soon is
the most important tool I’ve ever encountered
to help me make the big choices in life.
Because almost everything — all external
expectations, all pride, all fear of embarrassment
or failure — these things just fall away
in the face of death, leaving only what is
truly important.”
This may have been one of the reasons that
he refused to get surgery.
From his perspective, getting surgery seemed
unnatural and intrusive.
And this went against all of his hippie and
buddhist beliefs.
Jobs did eventually make the leap though.
By the time he died, he would go from refusing
treatment to trying to get experimental treatment.
In 2009 for example, Jobs would travel to
Switzerland to experiment with a radioactive
isotope.
The isotope was supposed to attack the faulty
hormone-producing cells in the body.
He would also try to use his money to accelerate
the process of getting a liver which many
people felt was unfair.
He didn’t cut lines or do anything illegal,
but what he did do was sign up onto liver
transplant lists around the world.
This increased the chances that he would get
a matching donor somewhere.
Personally, I don’t think this is a problem
given that it’s only natural that you try
to use all the resources you have to try to
save your life.
But, some like to argue that this is not something
that the average person would be able to do
and so, it’s unethical.
Let me know which side you guys stand on down
below.
But, anyway, the saddest part of this all
is that Jobs would eventually regret his early
choices.
He admitted that he was wrong for rejecting
professional help, and this is just made worse
by cancer experts constantly affirming that
he could still be alive if he had just had
surgery earlier.
But, in the end, everyone dies at somepoint,
but not everyone lives.
This, however, was never the case with Steve
Jobs.
Since the age of 17, he lived by the quote,
“If you live each day as if it was your
last, someday you’ll most certainly be right.”
And considering his impact on the world, there’s
no doubt that he lived by this slogan till
the very last day.
Are you a fan of Steve Jobs?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if hope Jobs is resting
in peace.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.